the vast majority of people that are in
their 30s or 40s that look at the
current world of insta tinder dating and
sort of free and easy sex that's become
decoupled from making babies or
relationships would get eaten a live if
they entered the modern dating market
chase reeves welcome to the show oh
delay how are you doing good man how are
you very well i saw a quote the other
day from uh jason parkin who said
except all of your heroes are full of
[ __ ] your heroes aren't gods they're
just regular people who probably got
good at one thing by neglecting
literally everything else what do you
think of that yes i think yes
i think it puts me in mind of
there's a singer-songwriter named ryan
adams
who i loved for a long time and i had
several opportunities to go see him
but never
always choosing not to for exactly that
reason like i didn't i wanted to
continue enjoying
his music the way that i had and i just
felt like it was going to change it why
because
i've had that experience a lot where you
you realize the humanity of your heroes
and it's an important it's an important
thing to learn if you're in the world
like making stuff
i fancy myself someone's future hero i
think at least my sons my daughters
maybe
but
experiencing the humanity of people that
you have idolized in some way
can
like i've it's just happened a lot it's
happened a lot it's been a big part of
like you know modern wisdom it's been a
part big part of like coming to
terms with how
life ends up really working that point
about them neglecting all the other
parts of their life
it's like
alan watts huge fan of alan watts right
well if you've learned more about how
his days ended
it's like oh wow that contextualizes
alan watson how does it day end he kind
of he basically he died of like alcohol
consumption
and
there's
it's it's not fully
uh
there's still some you can find on
online some writings from some of his
friends going like i mean here's the
deal guys alan watts you can hear him
and several times going i just like
drinking you know
i just like it um and that was kind of a
part of his
spirituality in some ways not the
drinking but just like the being into
what you're into
but
he had some speaking gigs booked there
was stuff that he was looking forward to
doing in life but he expired
right and you just think my buddy jay
always brings that up to me about
because he knows i like alan watts or
something and
it's that i i'm a follower of spiritual
teachers oftentimes like a ramdas is
meant a lot to me and stuff and uh i
love that rum dust will say something
like my brother calls me rammed ass
you know
i love the humanity there and you also
get to hear stories of rum dust is a
very sexually active guy through his
life you know
we put people on pedestals
we project onto them what
i like kind of i'm projecting onto them
based on where i feel like my inequity
is or something like that where my
detriments are that they fill in all of
the fall abilities that you have yeah
they just provide the screen for me to
constantly criticize myself in order to
get better you would be more like alan
watts you would be more like rhonda why
can't you present
yeah humanizing to realize the shadow
side or the the humanity of
the lack it's the light i think the
shadow side has a degree of sort of
beauty to it but when you realize that
christopher hitchens died because he
smoked cigarettes
probably yeah or the fact that you know
really alan as one of the
most popular spiritual teachers of the
1900s you're going to be defeated by
alcohol yeah right you know it just
seems like it's such a banal
unceremonial way to go and yet i i would
interpret it through the lens of his own
sort of uh
perspective around like life is here
for you to explore
what you want about it and he's like i
like it
aubry said the same thing the first time
i had him on the show he said life is
for doing the things it says you're
supposed to make love and travel and
take drugs not all the drugs but some of
the drugs and live and be where your
feet are and and
naval also says that it's far easier to
achieve your material desires than to
renounce them and i think that the same
can be true for adventures and just
doing stuff in life i have a friend
that's a uh used to be in a pickup
artistry in his twenties you know he
once told me um i was like [ __ ] dude
you're really passionate about pickup
artistries
pick up artistry pick up artistry oh so
he was he was a professional shagger
basically yeah and yeah i was pretty
impressed dude he really committed to
this thing he's like yeah my future wife
better thank me
oh you're gonna have to i want to check
the album you're gonna have to explain
to me about how your future wife about
it so well you know in 15 years time
when i'm walking down the street with my
wife and my two kids and my dog
i don't want to look at a brazilian girl
and think i wonder what it's like to
sleep with the brazilian girl i want to
have ticked off all of the different
sort of sexual
open loops that i've got to to close
those and although that was absolutely a
cope on his part to just
like dude math you know yeah it's like
dude
not really coming to terms with maybe
you're awakening an appetite that finds
itself very hard to settle mary
harrington's got this thing she calls
the law of fap entropy which is whatever
you start out wanking to he's going to
progressively get more intense over time
i feel like i'm watching i've watched
that in my own life like like worried
about that like i'm constantly worried
about that if pornography comes up i'm
like scared you know what you want you
want to just have a couple of favorite
porn videos and just stick to those some
classics i mean i think what i want is
none of that
right what i want is a really rich and
vibrant connection with my spouse you
know who i've been with for 17 something
years right but even on the way here i
was thinking about this like this dream
of like of of life like my i was just
with a native american teacher and he's
like telling some story of an of an old
native american character who's like he
said one prayer to god
five words i want a good life
and that's it he's like he prayed it
once and it was and it was great he's
like he did the medicine once and then
that was like that's it i've had enough
you know his whole entire life and then
had that great life but driving here i
was even uh
i i'm not uh i'm not
one who like i have i'm often times in
maybe not often but i have i'm no
stranger to that moment where you're
like
i would almost rather be dead
than to keep going and they have all of
this overwhelming
endless amount of stuff to do and
comparing myself to those heroes and
what could i do and not being able to
connect to the richness of right now
because it's like i don't know if it's
the life that i want like with the kids
and the wife and the whole life feels
intact you feel you can feel really
painted into a corner unless
you do some of that sort of spiritual
jujitsu or aikido as you were telling me
it's going out of fashion
apparently so yeah we're next door to an
aikido studio at the moment what does a
good life look like to you
i am one who is really connected to
creative creative work
so there's something about being able to
make stuff that people can enjoy there's
like
as a creative
as a person who has
done a lot of creative sort of things
there's stuff that i make that i enjoy
the making of
and i enjoy it for me
there's also the experience of other
people enjoying your thing
and then there's also the experience of
making something that you know is good
but other people like maybe it's not
popular other people don't enjoy it but
some small group out there you know does
but you have zero interaction with them
you know
so what makes a good life one of those
things is creativity for me
and not just
i get to be creative today like it's
it's also
the
impact like i had this
theory that and
like an artist is not just committed to
the work it's it's commit there's a
commitment to how the work is received
not that i can change someone's
preference about it but like knowing
that there's people out there that can
have this experience with that work or
an experience with that work
so creativity is a part of it i think
richness in relationship
like the
i'm a i'm like a youtuber who like talks
about everyday carry and bags and travel
and all this stuff and it's like the
stuff that we carry with us well the
relationships are really a big part of
what we carry with us
how i feel about specifically my spouse
and my kids
my parents
the
quality and the intimacy i have with my
friend group right where where my
friends are how their lives are going
too it's like we kind of carry each
other
so that's a that's a
definitely a
a big part of it i think of for me i'm
kind of a sheltered kid you know sort of
an evangelical for a long time and
um and i just
there's a lot of there's a lot of the
the sexual
experiences i i i've held it on my
shoulder that i haven't had a lot of
those
and i'm trying to
put away the like kind of the
there's like a child likeness in that
that's like totally relatable and and
beautiful there's also a childishness
that can like a juvenile side it can be
really juvenile and i can see that in
plenty of my 30 plus single friends who
are out
just
getting into it and enjoying it because
the the like you're like your pickup
artist friend like there is such a
thrill in the hunt of it my name is
literally chase you know there's a
chasing in things and then you have it
and then now what's it like right and
i'm constantly telling my dude let me
let me provide a little bit of a red
pill for you as here somebody who's
spent a lot of time around people that
are going out to sleep with new people
on a weekly basis in club nights right
you've been with your wife she was the
first person you ever slept with yeah
yeah and you've been with us for 17
years yeah
um the vast majority of people that are
in their 30s or 40s that look at the
current world of insta tinder dating and
sort of free and easy sex that's become
decoupled from making babies or
relationships would get eaten a [ __ ]
live if they entered the modern dating
market
not that they wouldn't be able to
pull not that they wouldn't be able to
go home with people but that what you're
used to the sort of connection that
you're used to
it is so much more vapid and hollow when
like the the most exciting part of going
back with somebody is if it's after a
night out or you've been out for dinner
or you've been out on a date or you're
driving over to their house for the
first time or whatever it's the drive
it's the anticipation it's getting there
and not knowing what to expect it's a
degree of uncertainty and excitement and
stuff but a lot of the time if it's
casual sex
the post nut clarity yeah will hit you
in the face harder than you can possibly
imagine and you're laid there thinking
like
not why have i done this or like what am
i doing but there are there's some
existential crises i can't i think it's
nietzsche who said um after copulation
the devil's laughter can be heard right
and in that moment guys
the the post clarity is a hell of a drug
man it really will take your face off
that is
for the most part the experience that
you have
you know the sex bit you know even if
you're an absolute stud is what 30 40
minutes long and then
you've got all of the lying in bed and
pillow talk and realizing that you're
incompatible and yeah the drive home and
the uber can't get here and how do i get
what's the code to get out of the gate
at the back of the house none of that's
romantic none of that's exciting no
right real life has so much of that like
just regular partnership stuff in it and
like i
i'm constantly in that sort of frequency
with some of my my friends
who no they they're they're wise to that
and they still get all hopped up on just
the energy of the chase and the
hunt and the
and
and i also hold them through
the feelings of rejection
you know the hood on the other side had
a buddy who uh was in a relationship and
recently sort of got back into the
dating market having i think despite the
fact he was very experienced in it
romanticized what the dating market was
like and then was reminded of
ghosting and chasing and girls that want
to just talk about themselves and
it's absolutely got to be the same awful
experience for girls as well and then on
top of that for women you've got the
physical vulnerability that they have
where they've got this entire new
separate type of fear or concern around
their physical safety that they need to
consider yeah
and uh dude it's i mean it really
doesn't surprise me i did this meet-up
last night for with rob henderson at
cosmic coffee in austin it was so cool
and to the people that are listening
that came down
thank you because it was way more people
than we should have had there is an
entire corner of this huge outdoor place
that was there and uh i was talking to
this girl who was born in idaho a very
religious upbringing she'd driven from
dallas to come to this meet-up
and uh i think so what do you do i'm an
icu nurse
what are your plans moving forward what
is it that you want to do she says i'm
just waiting for my husband
i was like
okay
that's the first time that i've heard a
woman say that that's a real vibe you
get you get that in a lot of in a lot of
places my wife's the oldest of ten kids
a lot of her sisters that's she was
she was like the middle of nine yeah
yeah and so that religious upbringing
makes makes sense in that world um
which is not like it's not necessarily
an unwise position it's certainly not
popular in the
you know in in what what women are told
they're supposed to want and be in
modern culture or whatever you know i
think of this quote from joni mitchell
who said if you want to have sex with
the same person again and again and
again
sleep with lots of different people
what's that mean to you
it's i think to her point there is is
like you do the same [ __ ] moves
you experience the same moves in these
because there's such an energy to that
honeymoon sort of beginning of a
relationship i love that feeling
right
and um
you find yourself in that same energy
again and again and it's easy and it's
curious and there's you just it's it's a
chemical romance you know
and then what happens
down the line like her then as she said
if you want to have sex with a lot with
like like a lot of different people like
sleep with one person
because you're going to go through all
of these stages of life with them
and i i'm like i kind of
i sense some of the wisdom in that i
certainly sense the intimacy and the
depth of connection that can happen over
a long period of time with someone and i
also certainly
can relate to the challenge of
commitment
to someone when you are someone who's
used to options optionality
and we call that freedom
you know
that that can be a kind of a curse
around being able to go deep well how
much freedom is there in going on a
night out and feeling like you are not
worthy or you're somehow less if you go
home alone
that doesn't sound that sounds like
pressure they don't like that pressure
and that for a lot of guys a lot of guys
young dudes is how they feel they feel
like there's an expectation around being
a young guy
in a single sexually liberated society
yeah that
that's supposed to go out and what the
the people on tv and the people in
movies and the friends that they hear
about do
is they go home with girls so if you
don't pull the whole culture man the
whole culture is set up for that like i
was raised on mtv
and it just you're just absorbing
messages around that
through through everything it seems like
and i'm i've
done pretty good
not
like
not living that coming to it no i mean
like i but mentally inside you're kind
like there's always what are the
archetypes that you're being told and i
think that that no matter where you like
i'm interested in your quest and your
question you asked her about by the way
like where where are you going what i'm
curious to you how important do you
think it is to have a clear objective
sort of goal like and if you could like
speak a little bit to
how you see where you're going
i'm not very good at doing long-term
plans man i've always sucked at them you
know the whole what do you want written
on your gravestone thing in terms of
especially actual outcomes i've never
been good at it's always made me feel a
bit i don't know insufficient or or
deficient in some way and i've got these
friends like ali abdal you know famous
productivity youtuber and he'll just
blew up yeah look at him like out
now what am i doing with my life but
he'll have on his wall
some unbelievable framework written by
the best
timeline
guide writer of the 1900s and he'll have
mapped everything out that's simply not
the way that i work and it never has
been and i always felt a little bit
deficient because i felt like being in
this space
and
flirting with productivity a little bit
which everyone does anyone in knowledge
works flirted with productivity it felt
like i should have that stuff unlocked
and i've never had it sorted it's never
worked for me the things that i found
that have worked for me
are
find a thing that i'm good at
go very narrow and deep on that one
thing develop skills and then broaden
out from there and that seems to be the
best way you know so
principles scale very well principles
and values scale very well and they're
very flexible so
the way that you have principles and
values around your relationship with
your wife will inform the way that you
run your business it'll inform the way
that you show up with your friends and
it'll inform the way that you negotiate
with the waitress that brought you the
wrong dinner at a restaurant
those are things that for me
if you struggle to
plan and make plans sort of where you
want to be in five years it's always
felt like
i don't know it's the same as people
asking you what's your type what they
mean by what's your type is what's the
very narrowly defined physical
attractive traits that you want from
your partner like kind of like what have
you seen in the past that you want to
keep seeing and it doesn't really speak
to the you know alan watts
back to to to this point on
bad at long-term plans he's like you
actually want to be surprised
you're trying to act you you you want it
to be a surprise too you will yes i'd
like to have the financial means that
i'd like to have
and i want to feel like i'm going to
dance with with really with the universe
but i see that through the people
through the businesses through like the
the opportunities through
whatever i want to feel like there's a
co-creation and a dance partner like i
step into the space and and it's
stepping back and then vice versa and
like well that's excitement right yeah
it's intrigue that's play and it's
connection it's like an intimacy it's
like i'm not alone
you know which i think
is
for people who are like
for people who are who are able to play
the field a lot and maybe be with a lot
of sexual partners or
like there is a a kind of a sense of
aloneness that i that i feel from a lot
of them not all of them at all but like
and i can feel like that too by the way
in a 20-year marriage right what's one
of those what's that quote about
this person's so poor all he has is
money
it's kind of the same as that this
person's so lonely all they have is
different partners every night
and
almost almost all of the stuff that
people are trying to recreate now a
sense of connection and belonging uh
variety and novelty through
whatever is different partners different
substances
it's filling a hole that you
you know that this isn't sustainable
like and don't get me wrong dude i've
done the party boy thing and that was me
i'm speaking this to my 22 year old self
right yeah
but
and that also is something that i've
been thinking about a lot recently
the lessons that we arrive at later in
life are ones that we wish that we'd
given ourselves when we were younger but
the only way that we've arrived at those
lessons is by living them
it's not it's not the case that you
could go back in time and tell chase do
this thing or i could go back and say do
this thing because i wasn't ready to
receive that lesson at that time that
wasn't the right place for me to have it
like if i'd gone back and tried to tell
myself a bunch of the stuff that i
really value right now
even if i'd believed me that it was a
true
realization yeah
i probably wouldn't work it probably
wouldn't be right which i think is is
like
is why i relate to you in the having a
hard time doing the longer term planning
stuff because i did not know what i was
gonna learn and what i learned was
essential and i wouldn't have had that
on my [ __ ] five-year plan
you know um and i'm
and i do like back to that
what is a good life like some i love
learning
like that sounds super silly and cheesy
for me to say but it i mean to my to
myself but there's something to i really
do have an inner drive to understand
like what are we doing here and
again and again i i'm
i experience that we still we really
don't have a great idea of what we're
doing here like you'll listen to john
verveiki or learns about some union
ways of looking at things and you go
like actually this this feels like it
helps me make more sense of what's going
on but it is it sounds hokey to a lot of
people you really have to kind of
make some you have to be converted to a
few things to even just be in the idea
of a collective unconscious or
archetypical energies or things like
this right but they do like what is the
psyche
is
such a big interesting question to me
like i don't know if i am
would say like what is a soul or any of
this stuff because i just like feels
like semantics i really don't know what
we're talking about half the time but
i'm trying to live very soulfully and
that feels like
it would be rad to
and not just it would be rat it's like
it feels great
when you're in that kind of rich soulful
connection with people and you feel that
kind of rich soulful connection with
life in general with like your own karma
or whatever you've got a quote that you
like to talk about which is the only
authenticity is authenticity about your
inauthenticity what's that mean to you
well i guess it kind of plays to that
to that kind of the viscera of our of
our humanity or
like be where you are that's the most
compelling thing
not who you're trying to be
and i'm just someone who's tried to be a
lot of my life i've tried to be tried to
be tried to be and i can be
charming
enough in some certain situations to
make you believe that about me you know
now playing a persona yeah or or and
oftentimes like i think what's really
motivating is just please don't reject
me
you know just trying to get people to
to
want me or like me or something like
that so to that
sort of avoidant
anxious attachment sort of
just it's so [ __ ] basic it's so it's
so lizard brain
you know well it's i think
it fundamentally comes from a fear of
the fact that we're not worthy you know
like this is a one of the most common
patterns that i see amongst high
achievers especially male high achievers
that are solo rangers is that
they
they hope that if they're successful and
useful that people will need them not
that people want them
because they don't think that people
want them yeah they think that if they
make themselves sufficiently
indisposable the people will have to
want them yeah
yeah and
that's a pattern that can propel people
to really really good things you know
you can be incredibly successful driven
by fears of insufficiency oh man it's
isn't is is there any other way right i
think there is i mean you know so
peterson's got this experiment he talks
about where they put starving rats in a
tube and they waft the smell of cheese
in from the front there's a little
spring attached to the rat's tail that
judges the force of how fast they run
away and you think what these rats are
starving and that's the smell of food
they'd be pulling as hard as they could
then they do another iteration and they
waft the smell of cheese in from the
front and the smell of a cat in from
behind and the rats pull even harder
yeah okay what's the lesson from that
it's like you need to run towards
something that you want but also away
from something that you fear
and i'm not convinced that
i'm not convinced that everybody that
goes on to achieve great things is doing
it driven from a place of insufficiency
i think that most people are i think if
you were to look at most high performers
in the world most successful people
i think that on average high performers
are less happy
than people who aren't high performers
which is very bizarre yeah why would we
call the outcomes that high performance
gets success
when
there's a good argument to be made that
that correlates more with a more
miserable existence
what definition of success are we using
is this a useful definition of success
yeah and it goes back to you know your
heroes you don't know the price that
they pay to be them tiger woods yeah
unbelievable example you know like
greatest one of the greatest golfers of
all time but
who wants to be him yeah the only reason
that you know that you don't want to be
him is because his failures have
happened to be really public yeah his
wife chasing him down the driveway with
a golf club
falling asleep at the wheel or taking
half a decade out of the sport with
injuries of overworking himself
stories in
about his father they had a safe word
when he was a kid his father would
racially abuse him on the golf course
say these white people are never going
to let somebody like you play here and
they had a safe word like you would
during rough sex it was the e word and
tiger never said it the e word was
enough
he never said it you know in retrospect
that looks a lot like child abuse yeah
but
that's the price that you pay that's the
price that you have to pay to be
targeted but i also feel so shaped into
that mold by
the movies i was watching as a kid
like that idea of
you always push harder you keep going
you know what with those movies
[ __ ] predator
i don't know why why
how to tie it to that but predator i
watched predator a bunch
there was this movie called only the
strong best of the best a lot of karate
movies
you know but there's action movies
there's just like
those it's always a go one more mindset
yeah and and there's a toughness that's
required for life if you want to be one
of the greatest you're going to have to
sacrifice everything
and i still have i still want to be one
of the greatest i still do
and i do want a really rich
home and family life i want my kids to
feel connected to me i want you know
this is the
perennial challenge i think that people
that desire to perform well
have to deal with that
it's a lot harder to perform well when
you feel whole
than when your performance is filling a
hole inside of you like if there's a
void that the next accomplishment might
fill
you're going to be very driven to go and
do that
if you now no longer have that voyage
and you need to recreate that same
degree of drive without this
existential compulsion to go after it
dude that's a big challenge that's a
really big challenge yeah
yeah
yeah i mean to that it makes me think
again of of like
how you say you're bad at planning for
the future
you know
and i i wonder how much
young men and women should be
setting those goals i remember uh
there's this old video it's probably
still online of tim ferriss and leo
babalta talking about
goals and tim was like you got to have
goals and leo was like no you should
dissolve your goals you should
let life happen as it as it comes and
continue to pursue your curiosities
and
let it surprise you and i i fall more on
that line but maybe because it's a
little bit easier i do feel some
pressure nowadays i feel like i could be
a little lazy about not defining what
i'm really going it's a definitely an
inner citadel that you can retreat to
right you can say look uh i find
planning hard therefore planning is
pointless it's like
that's a cope yeah that's a cope from
everybody um but in the same way as
if you're ali abdul or tim ferriss
perhaps it's fantastic for you to have
the plan laid out yeah but if you're
you
maybe it doesn't align quite so much is
exactly the same as there are people out
there friends with a bunch of them that
are really really successful are not
driven by some fear of insufficiency
they're perfectly secure in their
attachment yeah you know and
it's not horses for courses you just
have to think about what is the price
that people pay to to do the things that
you admire from them and um
yeah i wonder i i wonder as well about
the lessons that it teaches young people
about what success means and what they
should be chasing after in life and
things like that yeah and you don't have
that grand narrative anymore that you
know you and your
fellows from your 20s would have
deployed to people right you don't have
a single unifying mythos yeah that's
bringing everybody together so
everyone's now trying to reinvent it so
what's your take what do you if there
was a me like a single unifying
narrative right now if there was a some
sort what would your take on that oh god
what i mean if you had to swing the god
the the the
the altar that a lot of people are
praying at the moment is meritocracy
it's merit right
your successes are yours to bear your
failures yours to bear alanda barton's
got this great example where he talks
about the change in language over what
we
used to refer to people that didn't
achieve in life as and in ancient greece
they'd be called unfortunate because
lady fortuna hadn't blessed them yeah
and i'm pretty sure fortuna lady fortuna
is the
statue that's got the two
scales
uh and the reason for the scales was
that
you give and you take that people
understood that sometimes you would be
given and sometimes you wouldn't i think
it's maybe epictetus or one of the other
famous stoics um had lived his life in
sort of grand luxury um maybe the
assistant to one of the emperors and
then he got thrown in jail at the end of
his life and someone said you know how
can you deal with this he said well look
at how much of a luxurious life i lived
up until now you know lady fortuna just
got around to me recently and
the language changed and it was no
longer the unfortunate it wasn't that
this person had been dealt a bad hand
they're now called losers
like no no if your successes if the
people at the top are worthy of their
successes yeah
what does that mean the people that are
at the bottom yeah they're also worthy
of their failures and that for me seems
to be
it's a very uh unempathetic
way to drive society forward but it's
really good at motivating people to go
after it and yeah put more hours in but
it has built into it that some are not
going to absolutely it's a zero-sum game
yeah you know not everybody can be the
ceo of tesla yeah but everybody like the
whole point of being a top one percent
owner or a top ten percent owner is that
if you get in
you inevitably knock the person that was
that space back down one yeah that's the
way that it works yeah does it it's so
interesting when you look at even the
way that schools are done now the way
that the grading is done at least in the
uk
it's done on a distribution
so
every single year you take the total
number of grades and the person that is
the best in the entire country is the
highest the person that's the worst is
there and then everybody else just gets
smeared across this and they fill in a
predefined distribution there are this
many a stars in this many a's and this
many b's and c's
and that's how it's going to fit so it's
literally baked in from childhood
that a zero-sum game is how society
works yeah
yeah that doesn't seem like a
particularly wholesome spiritual way no
to fulfill can you tell portugal i can't
yeah i also need to
give a shout out to toppo chico as a man
that was certain
that he didn't like
uh sparkling water
san pellegrino just never gave me the
hit that i wanted
those italian bubbles just don't compare
mexican bubbles man that's what we want
uh it just it's an elite level of water
but most people in the uk even the
people that are in the sparkling water
they're not aware of this have you also
noticed there is a degree of um
like there's a certain net worth that
people get to
after which they're no longer prepared
to have
still water it's like when you reach
whatever 250 grand a year in income
you've got to drink sparkling water and
then tell all of your friends about it
well where did sparkle i mean
like
there's constantly sparkling water in my
house now
that's like
three years old as a market almost it
seems like you know i know you could
always go out to europe and be like
would you like stella sparkling but like
here in in in the house
it's great i live for it right just at
least a few those first three sips when
it's still ice cold
it's not hydrating
bad for our teeth
you like you it literally doesn't make
you less thirsty right like it is a hit
it's like as bad as a hit of anything in
terms of sensation super sensory
experience but it's kind of nice to like
have something cold and bubbly it is a
good taste man but toppa chico if people
think that they're not a sparkling water
person they need to try out turbo cheat
coats so i wanted to talk about feral
girl summer
which i saw in the independent a little
while ago feral girls summer is the
latest dating trend to make single
single women feel inadequate a new
tic-toc trend is encouraging women to
embrace their authentic selves but what
does it say about the pressures society
places on women without partners so as
you might be aware hot girl summer was a
thing that was promoted was it by
who did it megan this megan d stallion
uh to capture the post pandemic spirit
of last year trended on tick tock and
instagram hot girl summer uh and feral
girl summer is about not shaving your
legs
it's about thinking it think flea bag
with a sprinkle of someone who has been
at glastonbury for three weeks
ostensibly the feral girl summer is not
about dating but as with hot girl summer
its definition is dependent on it
according to the dating app badou 87 of
female users felt pressured to have a
hot girl summer in 2021 with 71 saying
that this impacted their dating life so
feral girls summer is whatever the
opposite is of hot girl summer it's
talking about female autonomy it's not
giving a [ __ ] the attitude is similar to
that perpetuated by the cool girl trope
problematic yet this seductive depiction
of subdued femininity created for the
male gaze so this is somehow this is a
trend created by women for women but has
somehow been uh screwed back around to
it being a product of the patriarchy and
it's oppressive cis heteronormative is
that what they're saying that it's a
product of the patriarchy everything is
uh similar another tick tick tock trend
goblin mode
no i like that though goblin mode the
feral girl summer encourages women to
forego beauty rituals in favor of more
radicalized unkempt aesthetics you have
to be your authentic self in order to
qualify and that apparently means
throwing away your razor why because
conforming to beauty standards makes us
makes us bad feminist is having a hairy
leg supposed to make us feel empowered
when we have sex and if it doesn't does
that make us a failure so basically it's
a very unfalsifiable
idea that womanhood is um
archaic ideologies around womanhood and
this is something that's put forward by
men you go well
look at where most of the criticism
about women's appearances come from
it's not men it's mostly other women
men criticize men and women criticize
women that doesn't mean that there isn't
crossover but beauty standards
for women
aren't created by men we don't give a
[ __ ] about your new fast fashion and
whether pastel shades are in and whether
you remember a thigh gap when a thigh
gap was a thing
and now it's whether you've got like a
big boo a big bum
all of that came from women
to women it wasn't us but the feral girl
summer thing i just think it's it's very
very interesting because
it's
always it's showing very quickly this
sort of vacillation from one extreme to
another hot girl summer was supposed to
be the pandemics locked everybody down
some is here you're supposed to be your
best self and go out and be glamorous
with your friends and go to festivals
and wear white boots and stuff like that
within one year
it's now whatever the exact opposite is
well it makes sense they're really the
same energy
how do you mean like so it's the same
it's like they're actually not only yeah
they're two sides of the same coin right
so it's really the same
i i totally relate to the idea of of
trying to
trying to look a certain way
right i mean my whole life have been so
aesthetically minded but like not like
with necessarily good aesthetics right i
was like a hardcore kid in the bay area
all black and
you know i had like a neck full of
handmade beaded necklaces that showed
you how straight edge i was or something
like you have the black cross on the
back of the hand when we went to shows
sure let's go yeah so but like
the aesthetics like my brother says i
took myself out of the game
before i was before it even started
right like
um
they're the same they're they're the
same energy
because
back to the bit about authenticity
like you're
you you have to kind of know yourself a
little bit to try to be honest about
your inauthenticity
and i think it's actually quite hard to
be honest about your in in authenticity
um to even
to even grock it in any sort of way
right it's like it's actually kind of
running in the background a bit and it's
hard to to get back then it's harder to
get back there than it is to like try
something like this which is very clear
be hot this which is very clear be not
hot you know it's like oh this is this
this feels like the same thing b you
know b maybe she's born with it maybe
it's maybelline it's like b maybe it's
hairy legs maybe it's under armpits yeah
there's a a really cool uh thing i
learned about mimetic theory so you know
mimesis right rene gerard's thing um
people copy people that are of high
status right megan the stallion
high enough status to cause
millions probably of girls to think
about having a hot girl summer last year
now there's two types of mimesis i
didn't know this one is positive mimesis
which is when you model off somebody
that's high status the other is negative
mimesis which is when you don't model
off somebody that's low status so the
problem with trying to be a
contrarian or a heterodox or a cynic or
a skeptic a lot of the time that's no
more
nuanced or depth thinking
than the other person or if if
all that you do is reflexively be
contrarian to whatever the mainstream
narrative is
that that's no smarter than the people
that just follow it you've just inverted
whatever the algorithm is if it's the
same with you know what happens with the
vaccines and stuff like that that caused
a lot of people to be so distrusting of
mainstream media because they'd seen
them sort of flip-flop between different
narratives a lot that they became
reflexive contrarians and you go hang on
do you really think that the opposite
unthinkingly the opposite of whatever
the mainstream says is somehow a more
nuanced
position than simply following it it's
literally the exact position inverted
yeah and i've heard you speak of that
before that sort of reflexive
contrarian-ness and it's something i
really relate to i've like i i've
experienced that a lot like my my my
mind my head sounds like that often or
at least when i look back
over life and and see full like seasons
or or phases of my life that were lived
in something
that were that were just inspired by not
being like that yep right i mean that's
what this is in fact we've that i think
that's a really good explanation for
what it is it's two sides of the same
coin you had hot girls summer last year
feral girl summer this year and it's the
contra it's the reflexive contrarian
thing last year we were playing up to
what
men's standards were in terms of an
impressive it was created by megan the
stallion not a man uh therefore this
year we're going to disregard
typical feminine beauty standards and
you go hang on a second when you don't
feel nice
when you do that
that's also not that's not coming from
some [ __ ] bureaucratic organization
telling you about how you're supposed to
be it's just naturally what's in the
culture at the moment about what is
femininity and for the most part that's
created by women and this reflexive
heterodoxy reflexive cynicism skepticism
thing
it it really isn't a smart solution it's
no deeper but it gives people a little
bit more of a sense that they've done
some work right and it but it's like i
don't even believe this
i don't even believe in this world
anymore this world of bloggers talking
to each other about who's responsible
for this that any other first of all i
bet there's like
in terms of meaningful numbers of people
who are and they were like
thinking that this hot girl or feral
girl summer is important it's like very
minimal in terms of its significance i
imagine i think you'd be surprised maybe
when it gets down to the girls level
like that
people want a
archetype to latch on to you know this
yeah you know this the stories
throughout the ages
they want an archetype yeah but i guess
sometimes it's just like when it's 20
year olds like
like
oh my god
screaming about like i'm like call me in
like eight years like we're gonna we're
gonna get through some real [ __ ] you've
gotta leave let's like life keeps going
it just keeps going right like you're
having feral girl for a summer you're
having a hot girl for a summer
well i mean that's a good point the fact
that
what you do for the summer is a really
important thing
only somebody that's been around on the
planet for less than 20 years can think
that that's a big deal possibly i mean i
love the idea that you can try on
different [ __ ] we can try on all of this
stuff and cool go explore
try a bunch of stuff on right and
realize how maybe not closer to who you
how you want to feel you still are it's
like that jim carrey quote about i hope
you get everything that you want
and then realize like you still don't
have it
you know like you're still missing some
essential
bit
which is armpit head
it is i mean i i'm i'm around a lot of
women who are who are consciously not
not shaving have you ever shaved your
legs by the way no have you yeah right
how's it feel season of it oh dude so
you had a hot girl summer i had a very
hot girl summer back in the day these
are like these legs these these leg
hairs are like tree trunks by the way i
would only go up halfway through my
thigh because it's a nightmare going
higher i literally had hair shorts i
mean just getting
there's just more thick hair up there
hilarious but i just loved getting into
bed
with a clean shaved leg it you never
felt anything like it and then you get
one chill
and
all these little pricks start showing up
and it's done like it's over turkey
that's not plucked i relate to the like
to like i don't want to be shaving my
legs anymore right i relate to that so
much even though i like that was oh you
know i had my hot it was just a summer i
was doing that uh but it was i highly
recommend i have a buddy who does that
from
jitsu because he's adamant that it helps
him with leg lock escapes there you go
certainly it makes it more slippery yeah
exactly right okay so we've also got uh
white gay privilege so there's an
article that came out today
uh for lgbtq plus people of color racism
also impacts how they are perceived it
is a sad reality that being part of a
marginalized societal group exposes you
to hate discrimination and an unequal
treatment it's a fact well known by
people in the lgbt clue q plus community
who experience this kind of hostility
based on their gender and or sexuality
however
for people whose identities intersect
multiple marginalized groups there are
more things to consider for people of
color racism also impacts how they are
perceived and treated by wider society
so people from the lgbtq plus community
who do not have to worry about racism as
well possess white gay privilege i think
i knew white gay privilege was a thing
before we had a name for it lady phil
one of the founders of uk black pride
tells metro code at uk and this is just
the beginning of intersectionality
eating its own i think the fact that as
soon as you have intersecting uh
hierarchies of grievance and privilege
it's no longer enough to just be gay you
know douglas murray was sat in that very
seat where you're sad and he said that
because he's gay and conservative he's
basically straight now he's an honorary
straight
and uh
this i mean if no one can see that this
is the beginning of a circular firing
squad where the purity spiral just
continues to shave off people on the
outside that are no longer sufficiently
oppressed so hang on oh you're white and
gay
i'm afraid that that kind of means
you're not that gay anymore friend
you don't get to have the same
oppression olympics that we do yeah no i
i've heard a few gay men white gay men
before speak of things in this direction
that didn't have a term yet
but
and to the point of of like the the
again it's like the world of
the world of bloggers blogging at other
bloggers about what they should blog
about and and and it's it's like a
robero snake eating it's its own tail
kind of thing where i'm so disconnected
from that world it's not the world of
like how to say like
i i feel we've
we've got so much um
it's it's interesting like
existential
fear
is so high
in terms of like it's so hard to make
money or to get to a level we're
comparing ourselves to people who are
further and further and further away
from where we are now right we've got
all of this chatter this noise that
we're that we've got to deal with and
yet we're so
not everybody but we're so safe
there's i i think of i got to go on
safari in africa for example and uh with
my friend who who like guided us
literally on the ground on foot
lions and tigers and bears oh my like
you're on the ground there's a ryan we
were tracking a rhino for a long time
and then we got to this place where it
was like oh [ __ ] it's right on the other
side of that bush we could hear it
breathing
and it smelled us and it could tell
something was up and you can hear it
getting a little like irritated like
what's going on and when a rhino
just starts running and it could easily
just run in this direction and just you
know he literally just has a horn they
call a group of rhinos a crash of rhinos
because they can run like 60 miles an
hour and see eight feet in front of them
right they're like a group the group of
rhinos is called a crash of rhinos i
love the names of like a flamboyance of
flamingos and you know
but
in that space
first of all your nervous system goes oh
i remember this [ __ ] because we're
talking
millions and millions of years that's
what we're shaped by
oh i remember this that was clarifying
it felt grounding in a strange way
um
teeth and horns and claws nature red and
tooth and claw
we're so far from that not saying that
like
louis ck has this amazing bit is like we
should let one lion loose in new york
just one just one
so any time you're walking anywhere it's
like
a little bit more just don't i think
it's a bit more exciting just like yeah
i made it this time but the the distance
that we have from
from what it takes to make
civilization work
is i think uh one
reason why we're able to circle jerk as
intensely as we can around who
who is living in injustice which type of
gay person is the one that's got the
most oppression yeah well i mean
the problem that you have is that only
in a world that's this convenient would
you be able to lap with so many
different games that you're playing i
just i heard this quote the other day
which is so perfect and it said the
demand for racism outstrips the supply
[Laughter]
at the moment that's a fascinating idea
yeah and what you think about is that
the ibrahmax candies of the world and
the anti-racism trainers of the world
and the people who take the social
status from it not even the people that
make money you know just the people that
are able to tweet about it
the people who rely on racism to give
them their sense of self and position
and power in the world
need racism to continue so what do they
do they continue to expand the
definition of racism to encompass more
and more and more things i just re i
just spent um some good time with a
native american teacher he's a comanche
and
he's a descendant of quanah parker who
is the the last chief of of the
comanches and
and i
like
in experiences with him
like i get to learn so much about like a
land literally taken from people
and and
i connect
i just i love learning more about that
even though is actually really
visceral like to learn about like the
the fact that we're really on like we
really
are privy or or
accomplice in some way to this
to like these people live with this
and they keep they're they're still here
they keep living and quanah was actually
a really interesting
bridge between those worlds
um between his world and and the world
that that he like was coaching as people
like hey man this is coming we have to
do something about this and he's he's
like you can take our land but you can't
take our medicine you can't take our way
of life
uh
i
i definitely connect to that story i
connect to the i mean i had this coffee
book when i was young of martin luther
king and i remember in high school just
learning about the civil rights and just
going like
like just what the hell
this is
and it just defined me the this struggle
this like the the that that people
and that people hey that people were
treated that way and then and then it
just kept getting more intense the
layers of it just the realization of how
pervasive
this activity of of owning people
putting them to work the differing
levels of of who gets treated in what
way
uh different classifications of people
different i still feel very strongly
that we live in like a caste system
there are different sort of casts how so
just it just feels like i'm in the stage
that i'm in we all have i think i
believe in the opportunities for upward
mobility
and i believe in and this might sound
like a shitty [ __ ] bearded white
thing to say but this there's a kind of
a value in accepting where i am
as like this is my this is my level this
is where i'm at in life because then
because then i can like i can feed my
family i can i can do these things i can
feel the richness of it and not
continually strive i mean that's that's
yeah that's a an interesting way to look
at it that that's an inner citadel that
you can retreat to as well right or a
cope i've got to come to terms with it
right but the reason that it's so
satisfying and so reassuring and
comforting to get to is that it stops
the drive it stops at least a little bit
of the drive for more yeah i'm looking
for excuses to feel satisfied yeah
precisely but again the ancient greek
word for work used to be not at leisure
yeah like
it shouldn't be the case that you feel
like your primary source of value to the
world as a father of like
lots of children and a husband and a
creator and all of this stuff the
primary source of value to the world is
whether or not you can double your
income over the next five years yeah
that's not supposed to be the way that
we're supposed to value each other
but in a world which is bereft of
community
and connection and
[Music]
sense of
um belonging to the
wider mythos of the the
nation that you're in
what have you got yeah well i've got my
bank account and i've got my social
media followers and i've got my watch
time on youtube an endless possibility
yeah and i've got my ability to accuse
other people in my group of not being as
oppressed as me yeah and they're just
different all of that is just like i
lived in portland for 15 years and i was
really uh
sort of kind of by default in
in a world somewhat like that
and i've since just gotten so far away
from it it just does not feel like the
real world
at all it's no longer a part of any
conversations that i'm a part of not
because my friend group is super
homogeneous or anything like that just
because the people that i'm with this is
not what defines our
our interests and our curiosities day by
day like we're we're not uh
we're not personally motivated by it
like that and
and
so it's just like it's just lost so much
of its teeth the whole culture war thing
like you were saying about the
vaccination stuff where it's like all
right i kind of don't
care a lot about what the cdc's
recommendations are like maybe forever
it's like the bayou cried wolf isn't it
yeah if everything's racism then
nothing's racism if if everything is a
health health risk then nothing's a
health risk yeah and
after a while people only get so many
chances at
singing and dancing and shouting about
stuff before you just start to switch
off and i want stuff that's going to be
useful for our like i literally have to
make the future
i literally have to put food on the
table for my kids and and my family and
i literally have people around me who i
care uh if there's things going really
bad for them like
i i want them to go better so i'm
looking for
meaningful information and insights
about where the world is going
about what what opportunity is worth
investing in so that
13 years from now you didn't just double
down on something that's totally [ __ ]
evaporated
intellectual laughing whole [ __ ] about
yeah privilege and intersectionality
there's this really cool thing i learned
about the other day called fire hosing
with with so many competing narratives
in the digital age disinformation agents
can't convince you of any single
narrative so instead they overwhelm you
with many contradictory narratives until
you start to doubt everything and become
confused demoralized and passive so this
idea that like
just like so how valuable is it for you
to be off kilter and have a walk like
it's like now i can do something with
you if you're if you if you're unsure
and insecure now i can
like direct you in a certain way a
little bit easier
it's harder to have a
a sense of
place and direction
and stick with it
right that's what one of things is
valuable having a career it's like this
is the industry that i'm in and this is
you said in the car like becoming the
best podcaster you can be that's such a
direction it so has like bumpers on it
at the at the bowling alley you know you
know you know where are your guard rails
that you can follow right and that is
that can be a thing that you
get to
uh
i don't know that you that you that you
get to uh
you're hiring that direction
in a way that keeps you it's like a
rudder or a fin on a surfboard it keeps
you from going off and all over the
place where it's like okay you're not
being a good enough socially conscious
justice warrior you're not you don't
understand enough about the hardships
here there and other everywhere people
use
people can supplant that with a lot of
different things though
people can decide that the thing that
they're going to pursue is going to be
the most equitable campaigning
intersectional lgbtq plus
person that they can be yeah and that
that becomes their status game yeah and
is it possible to say that objectively
some status games are more virtuous than
others
i don't know i'd need like a philosopher
friend here to work that one out
but i mean in terms of adding value like
real world give me tell me what is
happening maybe maybe i'm totally wrong
right maybe there is a huge problem in
the black gay and lesbian community
where they're being ostracized by the
whites in the
lesbian and gay community i'm not sure
it seems to me like time could be better
spent on
other things trying a partner to get
[ __ ] delicious sex with
i mean it's not that hard if you're in
especially if you're one of the g's if
you're one of the yells it's a bit more
difficult because you've got you know
you've got two gates i don't know it's
like it's just not not where i live it's
like not where i'm from you know i just
really don't know what the weather is
actually a lot of action going on with
the g's a lot of action but i i do think
there's there's like a a spiritual
practice and a and a like a
recommendation i'm making to people
let's like
be what you're what you're in and if
what you're in is
like who has who is seeing the most
injustice then then like let's bring br
let that be your goal bring more justice
bring bring more justice and if that's
not what you're what your gig is i
certainly do believe that there are
two things one like we talked about
before there are there are certain
constructs like you were talking about
meritocracy and um and losers are like
like that word is just such a [ __ ]
yeah i have that in my in my inner
critic so
so hard like this the smell of the cat
wafting from behind me pushing me
forward and like i want that to lose
some of its power because i i want i
want that to i want that to actually be
turned in on itself until it dissolves
it doesn't exist anymore right loser is
not a real thing but that's it's hard
for my psyche to
to to believe that so there are some
constructs that actually make
losers and winners there are others that
do a better job of rising tide floats
all boats of less of a zero to some game
more of an infinite game right
we know like we need our schmackton
burgers and our and our big thinkers to
help us evaluate these structures
that's one thing a second thing is i
really do believe that how it's always
actually been is we come we're actually
building the society from the bottom up
we're actually we actually build it
these individuals actually build it but
that's that's scary think about the fact
that each individual does actually get
to contribute to the way that society's
built there are a lot of [ __ ] idiots
out there yeah there are a lot of people
who have got but as texas says there's a
you know a well-armed populace is a
peaceful populace right like the idea
that like we're not gonna get away from
that scariness yeah we can yeah there's
gonna be some proud boys and some
alt-right and some really far far left
and and there's
there's going to be that distribution
like you talk about the grades in the uk
there is that's the [ __ ] state of
nature right and we're we're going we're
on the spaceship we're on planet earth
as our spaceship i love the idea of
being other places i love the at least
the narrative it gives us right in the
in the solar system but the nearest
[ __ ] star beyond our solar system is
so far away
like we we can only lean on the idea of
a fusion and bending space and time and
stuff that it's like feels like we're
really close but it's still like i
believe it when i see it right is the
way a lot of people feel about it
but
that's the state of nature there's going
to be buffoons and idiots there's going
to be brilliant people people
you know we're all on the spectrums so
to speak right and i do think
civilization grows from the bottom up
and and
we need those structures and those
systems placed on top and we want
there's some that are better than others
and i do i do lean on my my bro daniel
smackenberg to help me figure out which
ones are which however
i'm i have to own my part of this and a
lot of that is is
is like the raising of my kids the be
the all the other people can i influence
them all the other kids like the
families at my at my kid's school like
the the clients that i work with like
all of this stuff the people who watch
my videos keep going i feel like the
scary like like the the mental health
concerns
are massive like
the way that i struggle with it i'm a
man of immense privilege
is like i wouldn't i don't know like
maybe some of these buffoons are better
at being happier and we have stuff to
learn from them in some ways however
there are consequences to our actions
and and
you know i don't know i've talked myself
into a [ __ ] pit here around think
about think about it this way that
you've seen the midwick meme right which
one is that so it looks like a bell
curve and at one side you have this dude
that looks like a neanderthal and then
in the middle you have sort of this
angry
specky sort of liberal person and then
on the right hand side you have this
sort of sage guy with his hood up and
the meme is all about the fact that the
guy that's really stupid and the guy
that's really smart arrives at the same
conclusion it's the person in the middle
the midwife in the middle which is most
people midwit that's hilarious yeah i
haven't heard this before michael mallis
popularized the term it wasn't his to
create but he popularized it so midwitz
right and
midwit appeal theorem says that
by definition most content has to appeal
to midwit because most people are
midwit's right and the content that
propagates the most is the one that
appeals that's the scariest thing on the
planet to me
this site this idea that that
i'm i'm a youtuber one of the things i
do is make youtube videos
as any content creator who's been doing
it for long enough can tell you it's
like there's a draw to doing things that
will become more popular content caption
and and
in the same way that you know our roman
magistrate putting jesus to to death is
is like putting it to the people it's
like
the people make bad calls oftentimes and
those midwits aren't the buffoons
they're not the ones who are the crazy
ones on the outskirts of society right
they're they're the all of us they're
the sort of we the people is the is the
feeling of it going back to what you
said earlier on about cognitively being
able to convince yourself of a lot of
different things you know cerebrally you
can get in
with your mind and convince yourself of
something that your intuition is
screaming at you to do or not to do
that's the danger right it takes an
awful lot of smart to actually be able
to convince yourself of something that
you know inherently in your being and in
your fibers is something that should or
shouldn't happen yeah and that's the
that's the danger of the midway it's the
dunning-kruger effect right it's this
sort of valley of incompetence that you
go through before you actually come out
the other side yeah but for instance if
you were to look at um
[Music]
how to
get in shape um like
lift weights eat protein
then in the middle it would be i must
optimize my fasting window timing to
ensure that the pre-digested enzymes
from my morning coffee of grass-fed
butter is blah blah blah down to the
other side like lift weights eat protein
yeah like that that's what you end up
arriving at the idiot and the the sage
are both the same sort of outcome and
it's the person in the middle which is
most people that end up over
complicating things and this is where
the status games come from it's like the
stupid person and the really smart
person it's like um
find job that you care about live in
place that fulfills you have family that
makes you happy
in the middle it's i must ensure that
all of the oppression in the world is
being completely ameliorated because i
need to compensate for all of the issues
that my ancestors have done like yeah no
place that you want to live with the
family that you care about doing a job
that you love like that's it and
you know over complicating things one of
the problems you have is that it's
really difficult once you start on that
path like through midwitery
you you can no longer regress back you
don't get to slow the car down the only
way out it feels like i have i have uh
oh maybe maybe right you kind of have to
go over the over the hill into into
somewhat of a sage territory or
something but there's you know in
buddhism there's this idea of chop wood
and carry water before enlightenment
chop wouldn't carry water after
enlightenment
chop wouldn't carry water right and
there's this one my favorite coffee shop
stuff and where bakery shops in portland
had this great thing on the the wall i
was like chop wood carry water listen to
neil young
that's the addition i probably wouldn't
i'm like i find myself less interested
in listening to neil young after the
spotify think about
the fact that um so many people that we
know that are in austin here are
deciding to do homesteading or they're
building ranches and stuff and one of my
buddies was saying hey man i've got this
ranch i've just bought this spot uh it
needs some work doing i'm going out
there most weekends and immediately i
thought to myself
i'm so down if you want me to hammer a
fence in
for six hours on a saturday afternoon in
110 degree heat
i'm there topochico would never taste
better that would taste good yeah um
but
hang in a second
why is everybody going to university
and trying to gain money and status if
you end up getting to that stage and
then all that you want to do is [ __ ]
hammer a fence yeah and you go that's
supposed to be you know
low
in
complexity
indigent laborer work stuff
and yet it's the thing that compels you
to go forward again it's like you know
the sage and the idiot arrive at the
same place there's another thing that
this quote that i really want to show
you from naval
and he says um
karma is just you repeating your
patterns virtues and flaws until you
finally get what you deserve
and it just made me think about the fact
that a lot of the time in life you see
people that are repeatedly successful or
repeatedly unsuccessful you're like
you're the common denominator between
all of these experiences man is it that
every one of your exes has happened to
be a possessive controlling crazy person
or do you cause something that comes out
of them or are you able to choose that
type of person or are you attracted to
that type of yeah i think there's this
really big
there's this really big insight that is
is so simple but it can really it can
change
it can change so much of the landscape
of your life and it is so
it's just around taking responsibility
for where you are
i find people are
i a lot of successful people i hear and
and i'm one of these like don't want to
take ownership of their own success
first of all so like it's actually
surprisingly easy not to take ownership
of the success that you that you've like
i'm terrible i don't feel successful at
all right and
i tend to take responsibility over like
the
poor things in my life the things that
are bad that i'm doing badly in my life
for sure that seems to be a little bit
easier however like there's this mentor
i worked with for a long time named dan
takini who's
for 40 years he's been just doing these
workshops these four day workshops right
now he calls them the revenant they've
been called a lot of other things four
days
no substance no psychedelic or anything
this guy is super shamanic in just
a windowless hotel room
and and you just get to encounter
yourself
amidst all these other people
encountering themselves and he's
basically saying keep your [ __ ]
promises
what promises have you made take
responsibility own your life take
ownership over your life these very
basic things but it's structured in this
exercises that you're like it comes
through in these ins insights these
revelations sometimes you pop everybody
pops i broke in the middle of it you
know it's like that's what that's what
happens in these things the pressure
just builds but that idea of taking
responsibility going like all right what
happens to me is going to be on me
and that says nothing about like that
doesn't mean that the universe isn't
here as a co-partner with you dancing
alongside of you it just means like what
you're in control of you're going to be
in control of you know and
what's the alternative that's so it's so
where exactly what's the alternative
what is the alternative well the
alternative is it's their [ __ ]
problem or it's their [ __ ] fault or
it's that it's because of this or it's
because of that or it's mom or it's dad
it's everything that that actually we
all get a lot of out of these narratives
right i never have i never have and this
is the other side i guess of um
whatever the solopreneur only child
syndrome thing it's great because it
means that you never have a victim
mentality but what you find is you take
responsibility for things that you're
not responsible for yeah and that's
pernicious in a different way i think
it's probably less destructive socially
but it's more destructive personally so
you know something goes wrong and you
find a way to make it your fault even if
it wasn't yeah that's taking too much
responsibility i tried to ask jordan
peterson this and i was like hey
you like people taking responsibility
for their actions
is there such a thing as taking too much
responsibility
uh i'm going to ask joker willing the
same question you know extreme
ownership's his thing like have you
considered about whether or not there's
such a thing as too much ownership
[Music]
what about if you start to scale
your
problems
you start to insert yourself into the
problems that aren't yours
how long can you do that before you're
no longer able to show up for anybody
even the people that need you yeah even
the people that you should
own that you should be responsible for
yeah and i do feel that there's a danger
to that it's all forms and constructs
right that and like you pin yourself to
any of them it's just like pinning
yourself to that hero the quote in the
very beginning like it's really it it
continues life keeps going
it continues to go you get converted to
an idea
and then
you might see more nuance and
perspective and find that to be like
like the tantrus would say like there
it's it's this it's the spectrum we're
suspended between two poles of this
thing so taking too much responsibility
is like one direction taking
responsibility can go taking not enough
is another direction it's probably some
you know niels bohr has this quote it's
like oh good we found a paradox now we
might be able to make some progress and
he was born was this like physicist
amazing radical what does that mean to
you what's that quote mean to you this
idea that like first of all to your
point about first principles and and
principles being things that can
actually scale and you can stick with
over time
principles tend to operate on like
things that last a long time operate on
paradoxes right it's like it's it's
you're
what's a what's a good example for some
reason all i'm thinking of is like
you're alive and yet you're going to die
like that's not a great example of a
paradox
my friend group we just did a like a
ceremonial weekend and we're an
inclusive group but we're also exclusive
that's a paradoxical right and it's in
the play of that
that
you
that the the i don't know that the
meaning is made but also that decisions
are made and that people who weren't
there a week ago are there today and end
up shaping the space in a meaningful way
right and people aren't there who could
have been there that like that would
have shifted in a way we may not have
been beneficial because that's it's like
paradoxes like i'm a i'm an alive sexual
being who has the freedom of the world
and i'm tethered to one woman on purpose
right
that's a that's a there's actually a lot
of life when you pull that apart stuff
that we can pull apart
ends up feeling like so taking too much
responsibility taking not enough
responsibility probably too simplified
of a construct life does tend to have
this like
more like oh let's pull it apart and
it's less of a getting to the answers of
things and more feeling the quality of
the question
and
may not have even coming to an answer
but still having to take steps and
directions and letting it come together
over time
chase reeves ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you do online where should they go you
should go to chase reeves dot co i've
got all the links to everything there uh
if you're interested in me that's where
you can find me i'm on twitter and
instagram youtube and i'm making videos
about
backpacks for the most part
i don't know how that happened good
backpack sir great backpacks i
appreciate you man i appreciate you
thanks dude what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you